a stocked kitchen old board games it's
got all the financial games like
executive decision and finance and Wall
Street and themed meeting spaces people
say it looks more like a second-grade
reading room than a trading pit I'm okay
with that
at betterments New York headquarters
Silicon Valley culture meets Wall Street
finance about half the company has a
tech background this whole side of the
floor is engineers the startup is trying
to rewrite the rules of investing with
user-friendly technology and low fees
compared to a 1% fee that some
traditional money managers charge
betterment clients pay as little as 0.15
percent for a managed portfolio of ETF
we use really smart technology to
automate a part of your life that
previously you had to spend a lot of
time doing founder and CEO John Stein
quit his job in financial services and
launched Fetterman in 2010 I built this
product for me and my peers who I saw
getting ripped off by the financial
services industry based on clients
investment goals betterment uses
software and algorithms to manage their
money we do things like rebalancing tax
management dividend management all
better than you could do them on your
own
and the result is that you get a better
return on your money and less time with
more peace of mind disrupting the
brokerage business isn't easy but
betterment is expanding rapidly the
company manages nearly a billion dollars
in assets and expect
grow four times per year no one else has
really reinvented the financial services
stack from bottom to top and what that
lets us do is provide a better customer
experience so we have our own statements
that come from us we have our own tax
integrations that come from us your
money moves faster because we're
managing that process betterment is also
growing in size expanding its New York
office space to add to its roster of 70
employees I think this is a great place
to attract tech talent the city where
people want to be and that makes it easy
to attract those great engineers and
this is obviously an exciting company
for them to come and work at as well